sometimes we forget that one of the
single biggest challenges facing our
planet is decided is heating up and we
have an opportunity against a ticking
clock to try and reduce the temperature
rise of the planet that we can't do it
alone the EU emissions trading scheme is
the cornerstone of the ease attempts to
address climate change and simply put it
is a way of encouraging a market-based
solution the design is basically to
allow those who are wanting to pull it
to pay for that pollution who created a
system of parents in order to emit
carbon you must hold a certain number of
permits if you want to pollute more or
allow more out you must buy more parents
so at the beginning at work very well
and then came the financial crash the
consequence of the financial crash
reward that manufacturing itself went
and a city michigan dip people simply
were not manufacturing and therefore
they were not admitting and therefore
didn't need apparent to allow them to
emit and slowly but surely the number of
parents built up into what we have today
a huge lot of families there is already
proposed what is called a market
stability in advance which is like a
bank account into which you can put the
excess allowances but one of the first
things we try to do is to double the
rate at which those allowances into the
bank so they've taken away faster and
one of the bigger challenges of court as
a continent is we have a lot of
post-soviet technology to the east which
tries to hear a problem and we need to
make a way through that by an innovation
modernization so we created funds again
to support the the Member States if he
needs to help answer that the challenge
right now is we have the structure and
the mechanism
we have the car if you like yes the
engine it just haven't got the ignition
key turning yet and until that engine
starts piling the change we are going to
be fallin behind
[Music]